[Applause]
we find this really quickly here oh
thank you thank you thank you no one
makes a film in a vacuum and cradle is
indebted to so many beautiful Souls and
talented artists that it it really just
makes me dizzy to think about it to the
academy to Sean and Hector and everyone
and of course to my fellow filmmakers
thank you
you are some of the most brilliant
people I have ever met and I count
myself incredibly lucky that I'm legally
allowed to breathe the same air as all
of you to Saad Haddad - Natalie Shaw
- Ryan J Stewart the musical voices of
the film thank you - sound designer
Hannah cubot - Margaret and Megan and
Jennifer and Tiffany thank you to try
Alexa Quran
Trevor Larson and Rosie Richards thank
you for lending your voices to this
story and I'm so beyond grateful for
your friendship and - Jason kogo-sama on
a matagi Matthew Stewart intrepid media
works a sefa Hollywood the sloan
Foundation and everyone who made cradle
possible thank you
to my friends - 2 miles - Becca - Sharon
in all of my classmates at USC thank you
for sticking by me these last 4 years -
Sheila Sophia Anna hensch data faculty
and Jason Michael Berman among so many
others thank you for believing this film
time and time and time again and also
major thanks to Donald at the USC Panda
Express for of the quick bursts of
energy that you provided during my
senior year
- Rebecca Meyer Larson who helped me in
so many countless others find our voices
thank you and you are so loved
- all my friends and my family who never
stopped cheering me on from the bottom
of my heart thank you oh my god
to my dad who sparked and encouraged my
creativity from a very young age and
taught me that pencils can make some
remarkable things thank you and I love
you and to my mom who picked me up and
picked me up and picked me up every
single time I fell who applauded at
every performance at every baseball game
every film and who taught me that both
hard work and love will pay off
exponentially I love you so much and
thank you it sometimes feels that we're
entering a time of unprecedented
darkness a time of fear and anguish and
and distrusts and I know that as long as
there are storytellers as long as there
are artists as long as there are
teachers and poets and everyone fathers
and mothers and so long as there is love
darkness cannot and will not prevail
against the lights thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]